okay that's uh now the main thing that
we didn't get into yesterday was the
unset boxes at the end and I'm sorry I
don't have my big my sheet that has a
big letter so that we can't get it very
well in it on the TV camera his dumb
let's see how how how much you can
enlarge just for fun I always wondered
about that maybe it's going to be in fun
you get up like that and then okay
here's an unset box okay why 34 and it's
who yeah very delicate that this at this
high magnification but that's said right
there where I might thumb is moving it
says unset box and what it means is that
while you're doing an alignment the box
has the glue in the box hasn't been set
yet so even though it says the glue has
been set to some funny thing is that
that's really just to be ignored while
an alignment is going on Tech is just
holding these boxes unset until until
reaching the final end of the alignment
at which point the maximum width of
every column will be determined and then
each box will be set to be equal to the
maximum width so that so if you ever get
if you ever stop Tech in the middle of
enlightenment you can see how much it
knows about the formula so far there
will be these boxes that are out there
almost in their final form of their
unset has a wide 34 and it then not then
you go to the next page and it'll turn
out that the box eventually does get set
and why 34 occurs here and this time the
glue has been set to zero that must have
been the widest one in that column here
the Y one has a glue set of something to
do to stretch it out a little bit to
make to make it equal in that column I
think there was a fill or something in
that column to make it work out so so
finally the last page you see what
happens after things got set in the
alignment was finished but the previous
page showed the intermediate step
another thing i also want to mention the
way some things appear before and after
being in a paragraph like ascend will
send when we had a send it was in the
middle of a paragraph and then after it
got sent to the output the send appeared
after the line that contained the same
let's see we have that shown that was
probably the thing that went out to page
one no I'm sorry that's not as it's a
lie it's not true the sin doesn't get
after him sign top insert would what
gets moved after but we but we didn't
get to see that so I'm not sure we have
any evidences of that kind of a motion
in this example knowing I guess not well
so the point the main point of vollis
was that tech is really building
horizontal lists and vertical lists and
and in math mode it build it builds
trees as its as its reading your text
and then then it puts them all together
according to these rules and so we got
to get we got to get to know that part
of the tool if we're going to see how to
bend it to other application next thing
I want to talk about is a little bit
more about the way the paragraphing
mechanism works I mentioned hanging
indent last week and I mentioned
looseness just a quick review of
looseness here's an example of a
paragraph that was typeset with lose
with four degrees of different degrees
of looseness the very beginning we have
it set loose minus one which meant that
this is a little tighter than the
optimum this is the optimum according to
text rules for that particular paragraph
this is a Grimm's fairy tale don't
bother to read it please and then the
same paragraph again with same loose
plus one makes the thing one line longer
and this is when it's plus two now if
the looseness is growing slowly you
don't you don't mind it too much
but it would be a very shocking if you
went from the first paragraph to the
last on the same page can we have this
just look at the page from from from
back from from afar a gradual loosening
up is tolerable but I no no I'm sorry
i'd like to see just the whole page but
only the spacing on not the words yeah
you'd see so so if I'd know if i put the
bottom part next to the top you see it
looks quite different but you don't but
you don't notice if it just gets slowly
so I meant but that's that's to avoid
Widow lines if you have to do some
fine-tuning on the end and you idiot and
you're really becoming typographically
concerned about things that some special
job for a special occasion to want to
tune it up another thing these
paragraphs can be made in any shape you
like so here was one here was a first
example of such a shape take this
triangle for example his is Blaise
Pascal talking about the triangle and I
have them and then now Michael from
Galileo talking about circles so this
just demonstrates that that take
paragraphing mechanism will also find
the optimum breaks for arbitrary sizes
that you might might want for some
important application usually that's
just for playing of course but the fact
that it takes the paragraph as a whole
means that it if that can can do what
what might seem as amazing look ahead
feet now I'm going to talk about the
details of how you have how we're going
how we can do some up this next example
in a few minutes but let's first see
what it is this is the same paragraph in
in which I've done ragged centered
instead of ragged right can we have this
on the screen the top part here this tip
upon its now this took that same
paragraph and it broke it up into
a number of lines which was as few as
possible and given the width that we
that we wanted who specified and then
all as equal as possible and centered
them all now the the in order to get
that effect it was all done by the
paragraphing routine and you could write
a macro and we'll talk about it later on
today how how this would take a
paragraph and it would and it would
Center it on the on the proper amount of
proper number of lines essentially
minimizing the the maximum white space
in each line coming in from both sides
but but this would all be done by the
same paragraphing mechanism just using
boxes and blue you type something in it
goes in as a horizontal list and a
paragraphing mechanism that's used for
ordinary paragraphs would just happen to
do this to the text now other things
that we aren't going to talk about in
detail but they're described in the
paper that micro class and I wrote
called this is the that's why our names
are on the top here you see and the
paper is called breaking paragraphs into
lines and it support it's going to
appear in software practice and
experience in about five months from now
the this example shows an example from
Pascal programs and it's another example
of how the paragraphing making mechanism
of tech can be and a proper combination
of boxes glue and penalties will do
unusual feats of typesetting on the
bottom example this is exactly the same
text is a program taken from the Pascal
manual and in this in this example
actually every line in this example is
one paragraph in the tech in the text
source file for this for this thing the
and so II and the indentation of each
paragraph has been determined by macros
and we have a preprocessor that will
take in any syntactically correct
program output a text file which will
list like this it can you know it
chooses the bold and and spacing in
formalism and Roman and italic and
everything by itself and that's all put
into the text file then the then what
you have to tell the tech file is what's
the column width that you want and from
the identical tech file that listed this
will also produce this if you say the
columns are narrow and so well each
paragraph is treated separately but the
but you'll you'll notice that the macros
who were set up so that the config they
would break up in reasonable ways and
they would continue of lines like a
continuation mind i think is to is to
indentation marks over from where the
next language start and and so on this
this tech file is is defined in terms of
a few macros that are enough it's called
algarve tech on texas as a set of macros
that are useful for displaying algal
like programs and breaking them
according to the to the constraints of
the of the margin at hand so in other
words this preprocessor does not know
what the margins are going to be it puts
out exactly the same in from tech
information for all size margins it's
the paragraphing mechanism of tech that
calculates but boxes that calculates how
to brake lines that actually decides is
Arthur but do you do nice things for
breaking this paragraph as you would for
a bath over the math formula is in fact
most of these are math formulas but I
mean will you prefer to break after a
plus as opposed to the for it yeah you
never break before plus it's because
it's done by a bit of math formula if
you look at it if you look at that text
source file has dollar signs are not
around things so
this is but it also includes this ragged
right feature and so on all I'll in
there now another example of what what
you can do with the right combination of
boxes flu and penalties is probably the
most complicated example I've ever
handled so far is this one where where
we where we have three examples this is
a is based on the indexes to math
reviews and neither three examples all
set from identical text source each
involving three paragraphs and the
paragraph paragraph algorithm that takes
a paragraph claims the optimum breaks
has types that these things from exactly
the same source file except that we
change the width of the lines so that
the brakes will occur in different
places then I'll notice what these these
index entries they start out with a
ragged right margin and then they have
this leaders these dots here which
sometimes occur at the end of a line
sometimes at the beginning of a line
sometimes in the middle of a line and at
the end after the leaders then you have
left then then everything is flush right
and it's left left ragged and all of
these things are done by bike boxes and
blue inside of the insight in the in the
input that as I said was the hardest so
far that I plication that I've that I've
handled with with these primitives that
tech users in its horizontal is but it
shows that unsuspected ly powerful
ability to handle typesetting problems
that don't look like ordinary paragraphs
out of Grimm's fairy tales still you do
it with exactly the same method that was
used to typeset Grimm's fairy tale now
how does week how can you use these this
this idea of boxes and glue and so on
which of them
kind of an optimizing method an indirect
method rather than a then a direct
method which says do it line at a time
and make a decision one line at a time
and the in order to understand that
properly you have to you have to read
carefully the fine print that says what
is tech optimizing tech is trying to
optimize what it calls demerits over the
paragraph and the demerits are are
associated with each line the demerits
on on each line are is something like
the badness of the line plus the
penalties on the line plus one squared
and so a line has badness associated
with it and it has penalties associated
with a break and and then there's this
other constant one that keeps you from
from preferring long constructions two
short ones now the badness of a line
called the penalties are easier so i'll
take the penalties first if a line ends
with a hyphen for example then there's a
penalty for hyphenation if there are two
let's see actually there's another ad on
to the demerits for for extra kind of
penalties like to Haifa nations in a row
you get an extra penalty added on or a
loose line following a tight line you
can extra penalty added on a few more
demerits but most but but the most of
the contribution comes from the penalty
associated with the line itself starting
at one point of paragraph ending at
another then you pay a penalty for how
how bad the space no effort for for
breaking at the at the right-hand margin
and the badness relates to the spacing
in that line so the penalty is this
generally associate with the right
margin and typically if if the line
broke at a penalty then that's what P is
penalties in tech if there are a
thousand or more it means that you're
not going to break the line at all but
what 999 it will break in
pay a penalty of 999 in his formula the
badness of a line is approximately zero
if the line is near if the line didn't
have to skip the gluten have to stretch
or shrink very much in a lot but the
badness gets to to a hundred if the line
had to shrink its maximum amount of of
shrinkage or it's a hundred if the line
had to stretch to the specified amount
of stretching now a line is never
allowed to shrink more than the maximum
on a string of shrinkage but it is
allowed to stretch double and if it had
to stretch or any amount it can stretch
much more than then if you say the glue
is like 10 points plus 10 points then
you can stretch that 200 points we have
the stretch if the 10 points the stretch
we're actually x 9 you get you get 90
points of stretching there but that
would be very bad so the badness is
something that gets very large when it
has to stretch a lot and the actual
formula is is is proportional to the
cube of the amount of stretching so that
if you if you stretch by the full amount
the badness is a hundred if you square
stretch double that amount to badness is
800 Alyssa yeah question does that mean
you can't force minus letter spacing
unless the font designer has set things
up oars what- letter spacing so that
unless the font designer has to force
pay to force to crowd letters together
that should be done in the font design
and meta fund does that for you that's
right but we don't know tech in fact
typographers don't like that and so tech
took their advice
the the the tightest line you can get is
to squeeze down so that the glue is down
to its maximum amount of maximum
negative amount and that would be a
badness of a hundred if you get if you
got a line that didn't fit at all so
that you wanted to to shrink it more
than the total amount of badness then
the badness is actually considered
infinity that's so that minimizing the
cold ameritz you you would find that you
try to avoid infinitely bad lines you
can overflow box if there is no way to
do without an infinitely bad line
without exceeding the badness equal to
100 times the jay park so if Jay power
is 8 it'll never allow badness to get
more than 800 if je pars to which is
normal for our type restrictions then
you never left la the basket more than
200 don't consider any any possible
breaks that that would be worse than
that if you want to ok that's quite
reasonable because some some lines are
so intolerable you only want to bother
considering them and it speeds up tix
texts algorithm if you if it restrict
itself to considering only lines of
bounded badness oh so we get badness and
penalties and then we square the whole
thing and then we sum that overall lines
we find the best way the best score for
the entire paragraph so now we have to
when we have our applications we have to
find a way to look good from the
standpoint of this formula exactly the
same method that's used in horizontal
lists to make paragraphs in two lines is
used also in vertical lists to make
lists of lines into pages except that
tech doesn't optimize over your entire
document to find the best way to break
pages in to break your whole document
into page it's tech only you will
optimize over a whole paragraph to find
the horizontal breaks but
for optimizing over the whole document
tech the tech doesn't do that unless you
use a special version that Michael has
for experimental purposes here which
which goes in two passes the first pass
writes out information about what the
document contains then comes in
optimizing that optimizing routine that
figures out the best page breaks and
then you go through the whole the whole
tech run again with a reading in a break
file that that uses that that says
here's where to break the pages
optimally according to to minimum
demerits and and the second pass up
produces that and Michael thesis will
can will it describe this in detail now
legal breaks can occur in a paragraph in
two cases maybe three depending on your
definition of a case the first case is
when you have glue following a box glue
following a box is legal break you break
out that glue then the glue goes away
and the box becomes is the end of the
line the second case is you break at a
penalty and anywhere where if someone
specifies penalty that's a legal place
to break okay with that penalty being
paid so you say penalty zero that says
here's a place to break without any
penalty penalty negative 100 say here's
a place to break and you actually win
and in fact we don't use that formula
when P is negative when P is negative
it's beast v plus one squared minus p
square when p is negative because we
want it to be a monotone function of P
so we want to actually you know take
away demerits if he is negative this is
pia spot
and as I said if the penalty is a
thousand then it's not then it's not
allowed as a break at all that's that's
in order to insert a glue which you
don't want to break so you have a box
and you want to follow it by glue but
you want to be able to break it that
glue so you say boxing you say penalty a
thousand then you give the glue no
button and glue can never break except
if it follows a box and you can't break
it a penalty of a thousand so you didn't
have any ways to break there that's the
idea of penalty a thousand now there's
the there's one other case of a line
break and that is where somebody
actually wrote a line break or eject in
his paragraph and that will force a
break that's like a penalty of negative
infinity very good place so if every so
every such place is forced to be a a
line break now you get to use the you
get to have to experiment ease tools you
get to appreciate the power of these
simple three concepts of boxes glue and
penalties and well combining with
demerits and and and it took me about
two years before I learned some of the
things you could do with them and
probably was almost a year before I
realize some of the some of the the
first non obvious applications of the
method first so the fun thing for me was
that I made up these rules just so it
would work for ordinary paragraphs and
then I found out months later that
without changing my algorithms I was
also able to do Pascal and all this
other stuff the one thing that is right
as fairly often applications is somebody
likes to say I'd like to end the page
now and start a new page if I'm near the
bottom of the present age okay
try to and then I give if I move to a
new page then I'll just leave the bottom
of the present page blank so it's sort
of a conditional look to see if you're
near the bottom of the page then fill
that page and and and and start a new
page if you're near the bottom otherwise
get the knittin you know start working
on on the next copy how do you build
that in well the fortunately it's very
simple you say like this v this is in
vertical mode at a point where where you
have a decision like this you say V Phil
let's say with one L this means skipping
this is the same as V skip zero point
plus one hundred thousand points and
then you say penalty zero example says
it's legal to break after the V Phil and
then you can say we feel negative which
is V skip zero points plus minus a
hundred thousand points now I forgot to
tell you one important thing at least
one that is that at a break then you
wipe away all the glue and penalties
after that from the point of the break
on until you get to a box afterwards so
so so glue and penalties disappear at a
break so so now let's watch what happens
then we had some text up here some text
down here and what does this mean to the
page layout routine these three lines
specify a optional break and start a new
page the reason is you either break at
this penalty zero or you don't by the
way I should proud put I ok I could
break at the v phil here but it would
it's always dominated by breaking at
penalty zero because having a little
March stretchability isn't going to hurt
so that we the formula for four demerits
for badness will always be at least as
good by breaking at the penalty zero as
breaking @v phil here so i don't have to
worry about considering what happened if
i break at this veal saw it all i choose
the best one when tech is out breaking
pages it takes the best one based on the
current one page at a time so it looks
ahead and keeps on going until it gets
into the next page until there's no more
until the badness now gets infinite so
that there's no more way to squeeze
anything more onto one page at that
point it chooses the best of all the
available breaks up and and outputs that
page and starts over again so we have to
consider two cases either it breaks at
penalty 0 or it doesn't break up Finley
0 if it breaks a penalty 0 then the glue
following it is also wiped out so the
net effect would be break the page here
fill the previous page start a new page
the other alternative is it doesn't
break at the penalty 0 in that case the
V Phil followed by V feel negative is a
no op this plus negative 100,000 points
cancels with this and so any stretch
stretching here is taken away from there
and that glue adds up to zero and
nothing happens and so the thing
continues so now tech is going to
consider two alternatives either to put
this next neck business on the click on
the same page or two to move it to the
next page and and the the difference
between the alternatives is based on how
well this thing that's coming up fits on
that page without any any any flexible
stretch of stretching allowed if that
second thing fits rather nicely then it
then we'll have a good situation
and and two things will fit we'll go on
the same page one thing for example over
the way I use this if I have a bunch of
items I put them into boxes so that this
box is actually a big box so this box
will either fit on the page or not and
so then the penalty then it will take
the break here if and only if this thing
fits on the page we're putting it in a
box means you'll never break it between
pages Arthur Oh what happens if you just
goof up and put a V filled egg in the
middle somewhere if the total
stretchability on on box that you're
trying to set the glue of is negative
but the group but the box was already
short it okay if the box is short you
and you want to stretch it the stretch
ability and stretch ability is negative
it it passes I think in just less the
glue 0 similarly shrink ability of total
comes out negative yeah is in going to
plus minus about 200,000 points is not
the same as going minus no I know that's
what the idea that the plus to cancel
out applause is giving the stretch
ability and the minus is giving the
shrink ability yeah merely to cancel out
a stretch ability somewhere else that's
right so so you can have negative
stretchability that's and and then the
total should always come out positive
though if you don't want some weird
thing to happen and it always will and
things in a situation like this so in
fact if you if you monkey around if you
just put arbitrary things in there of
course the optimum would would not make
any sense so the optimizing algorithms
do assume that there's some some
reasonable restriction satisfied on
these glue otherwise they don't bother
to optimize under the under under weird
cases all this is spelled out in very
great detail in our paper okay now this
this thing also applies induction
horizontally yeah yeah presumably in the
setup you have here the page will now be
broken so that there is no badness
almost no because the V Phil is have so
much stretch ability that is almost
human if you want to sort of work a
little bit to try to fit in something
could you simply reduce those I guess
you've got a hundred thousand points
could reduce them something yeah like 60
70 points and it would work yeah you can
play with this number you can also play
with this penalty number and gives
different effects so the Mounties to say
well maybe I should pay a penalty of 44
for a short page maybe you don't you
know maybe like to discourage it maybe
you'd like to encourage it by making the
tag penalty negative and you can twiddle
also with the badness by by this
calculation that's why you want to go to
your formula four demerits to find out
which which optimizes of course actually
just the yeah well on in the case of
pages it's a monotonic with penalties
but it chooses the I think in that in
the case of pages it's just be plus P is
minimized every page minimizes V Plus P
overall page breaks for that for that
pay okay now a question da another
question yeah that that example there
where you have the conditional page
break seems to be a good Apple one
application that I can see is to make
sure that like a section heading is tied
along with the first few lines of a
paragraph that's right because it
typically a second typically a section
when you start it out you'll say you
know chap are or section 3.1 and you
give a title and then the text of the of
the section will say we will now or we
shall cetera you know and there will be
a little bit of space here v skip three
point or something between the between
the title of the section and the
beginning of the text of the section you
don't ever want to break their at that
place so you would say penalty a
thousand in front of the V skip three
point
and that forbids a break there that will
force these lines coming in here
furthermore there will be a to avoid a
widow line there will be an extra little
line penalty will appear after this line
saying we shall and so there will be no
tech will discourage breaking after that
line so it will want to get at least
this and two lines of the paragraph in
before it even considers a reasonable a
reasonable break and then there probably
be some stretching or shrinking involved
that will make it a little bit
undesirable compared to this maybe not
so maybe you want to put this penalty a
little higher yeah just in terms of
numbers what would be considered a large
penalty for a page break or a small one
about how much 100 you have a think of
it this way a hundred means the maximum
stretching of all the glue and or the
maximum shrinking and so a penalty of
two if you're saying a penalty is
negative 200 you're saying that you
don't care if somebody stretches pretty
much you'd rather break here anyway if
you're saying a penalty of plus 200
you're saying this is this is going to
be so bad that that that probably it'll
dominate other other effects that you
know is you you you wouldn't want to do
this unless it was necessary to avoid
200 badness in some other in some other
break so you that's who the order 100 is
the is the round number that sort of
means that limit of tolerance and the
fact that badness when you're doing it
in one paragraph is cubed just means
that it stays near zero when week when
you when the drinking is is near zero
okay now before I go on I wanted to give
you some homework and this is a handout
that you can pick up the idea is there
are six problems here that if you can
solve these six problems then you can be
considered a
eligible for a wizard's license of
making these uh these uh and yeah the
six problems seem to cover the main
points that are necessary in macro
design and tomorrow I'm giving them out
today tomorrow I'm going to discuss
hints about them if somebody or has
questions about them and thursday i'll
describe the answers to them in just
overall and i'll also hand out answers
on thursday each of the problems can be
solved with it just a few lines of tech
coding and i can see exactly how many
but not too many you know pure than ten
i think in each case and and then on
thursday i'm also going to give up the
the the channel maybe even on wednesday
when you give out the challenge problem
that I doubt if anybody will solve but
just for just you know for those of you
who find these six too easy we'd like to
work on the challenge problem we will be
talking about that on Friday the main
ideas though new six problems are two to
focus on one aspect of designing macros
for users as you'll see the first
problem is the simplest one but I don't
guarantee that the others are in order
of difficulty the first problem is at
the top of the page when we have it on
the screen case this just this part here
and it was based on something that came
up in last week's class we had at the
left of a page there was a there was a
dash that we wanted to get into the
margin and so the source file just said
hide and put in push the dashing yes so
you have to be fine for this one dis de
finest control sequence hide now this is
a fairly common thing in typography if
we're never doing poetry for example you
have lines of a poem there often if the
line starts with a quote mark that quote
mark is supposed to be brought out to
the left and so that you would also put
hide in front of certain punctual
nation that goes at the left of lines
and when you're lining up lines of a
polymer or in this case this was at the
left margin of a book so design a macro
that does this hide that's problem one
problem too was another one arose in
that same book about Stanford and here
was the output and the input or is shown
below it you your job in that one is to
design a macro called fancy which which
set the S here and and did that right
now I should tell you that this s is
there is 3 is 30 point type and the
other are ten point question should
fancy have to work independent of what
baseline skip has been set to though no
you can assume the baseline skip is is
from basic right yeah right now it's a
possible to determine the baseline skip
as you probably know you just could say
for example vbox of each box no H box
know and and then you look at the height
of this box so you save this and you
look at the height of this box and
that's the baseline skiff the difficulty
those dividing the baseline skip into
the height of the letter to figure out
how many line y'all know I'm assuming
that this letter is that this letter
will go down by the same amount of the
base landscape so you can assume that if
you want that that you're in 10-point
type net guy just dropped down that
you've got a 30-point letter but it's
not really 30 points high its but what
they call a 30 point size that would
include the center's annual little extra
spacing and then that you bring it down
to you know such things as shown there
anyway and it should work just assuming
that there's a letter following word
fancy question yes but on that example
you have a I'll bring it back backup is
the base line spacing under the yes
still the same as their change it's hard
to tell on the screen
all of these lines are 12 points apart
it's okay okay that's the question I
never thought you'd either look like a
baseline skip at all look fancy is a
two-line macro one line if its lineup
but okay it is supposed to work if s is
a tie if s is it is an eye yeah any yeah
it depends on the size of the letter a
wider letter would move over a little
bit more but if it says I am you know
the word I well then of course the we
would actually have a space probably
there where the e is now okay well
that's the next exercise a third
exercise is one taken from math reviews
and again i gave the source at the
bottom that generated these these two
lines notice what the worldly lines
explain the problem you're supposed to
design in this case a macro called
signed and this is to go through the
paragraph so that text paragraphing
routine will do the will do the right
thing okay it will it will it's very
much like what i just told you in
vertical direction right except this is
in the horizontal direction this is the
end of a paragraph at the end of the
paragraph is the flush right in these
cases yeah so that the end of sign it is
assumed that that's the end of the
paragraph okay exercise for is this is a
we have to go back a little bit exercise
for is to produce these points from this
source input your gear your job is to is
to define a macro point that that looked
like there this was a source and and you
just set me right the tech coding for
point that produced this from from now
is ok this is to make diagrams assuming
that somebody's going to draw the lines
in
and okay now the next fifth example is
from this kind of a you're supposed to
define to macros in this case one called
right justify the following another
called end right justify and and this is
for people who don't like to type a lot
of you do a lot of keystrokes so you
want to set it up for the user so that a
carriage return is good enough to
recognize that that it should be right
justified so typist would just say right
justify the following probably you would
shorten the name of that if you were
actually in practice and then typist
would give as many lines azhar to be
right justified followed by saying end
and the right justification okay and
this is where it would come out now this
in this example suppose the person
wanted to write just a fire line that
went more that went two lines long well
then you could allow them to put a
percent at the end of one of these lines
and and you know to get to the next line
Arthur suppose one of the lines and
though that was fit on a law and the
source took two lines in the output you
want us to handle that it's gonna it's
just going to stick out and left margin
that's that you follow the instructions
computer doesn't doesn't worry about so
this is not going to be you don't have
to make it into a paragraph just use our
just line are just Linus is in basic
which accepts anything okay that is the
fifth exercise in the sixth exercise the
source is over here and I also had to
add the that I thought what I'm suming
for the baseline skip and line skip
between lines but the text was how do
you do this and then it did a vcenter h
align centering producing the macro
called line down look at this strange
pile and then it may it went down this
way this then I did the same thing would
be centered H line but now line up and
at this stranger one it gives me the
line up now what's the idea this is
lying down is supposed to produce a list
a list to tech that says L carriage
return 0 carriage return 0 carriage
return silence character k carriage
return space carriage return at and so
on strange comes out strange carriage
return because it was in brackets but
that's what that's what actually they
say twas H aligned here because the cuz
I I told you how they hover lying down
was used so so the output of lying down
macro is supposed to be this is supposed
to take its its thing and that's string
it out with carriage returns in between
line up is the same thing except the
opposite way it'll come out period
carriage return e carriage return and
ending with the a carriage return and
that's the output of those macarons
seems perhaps eyes to get this to work
because we I change what size emphasized
the depth of the recursive the stack no
I the way I done it it doesn't require
more in about five or six of the nesting
yeah Arthur can we assume that there is
a character doesn't appear in this mess
dollar sign
okay assume that there's no dollar signs
in there because they would be used for
a except for course for math formula
which would be allowed well but you'd
probably put it in braces if it were I
saw ok so i guess you can assume no
dollar signs in or some carrots some
thing like that yeah all right otherwise
it's there's a solution but it's more
difficult so yeah I'm going to talk
about how to solve these problems later
on this week those are the six problems
that are in the handout and now I want
to talk about how this this magical
centering operation can take place and
in fact one of the things that I'm
looking forward to seeing interactive
tech is to see how it would look to be
typing in to the centering macro and
having it and I add another word and all
the lines are shuffled around again and
resented themselves properly that should
be very fun to watch watch and could be
built in in fact the just the
paragraphing mechanism of tech is going
to be built into our son terminal so
we'll have that ability in our editor
anyway anything now all right so let's
take a look and see what what we want to
do now space between words if I want if
I want lines to be to be centered I
better get my cheat sheet here okay now
centered here we go oh where i'm sorry i
got assigned page trying to hear it okay
okay so now at the so now I've got I've
got there to put something at at the
beginning and i'm going to say h skip oh
the very beginning of the paragraph will
say no indent and then you'll say h skip
zero point plus 1 plus 1 m let's say 18
to 10 point or 1m let's call it one end
our stretch ability that actually that
amount is as you see isn't going to be
critical but i'll use it now then and
then will come the word like in and then
there will come another space between
words macro in olden and then we'll be a
space between words macro and so on so
all my space macros i'll just write
control space and and we'll talk about
how you get those in the paragraph later
but let's poke let's for now let's just
say that the spaces are all there so
that's the paragraph and then i have to
tell you what's the space they're going
to be then finally at the very end of
that paragraph there was the word play
thing and then it was then at the very
end I'm going to at the end of the
paragraph i'm going to say again a skip
zero point plus 1 m and break the and
that'll that'll be the glue that comes
at the end of a paragraph this is known
as the powerful skip and so you can set
power fuel skip to whatever glue is to
be placed at the very end of a paragraph
to death powerful skip would be said to
that now what about this base macro here
this is what goes on before between
spaces and I first explained what it
does and then we'll see how to implement
it now this is going to go
the following a CH skip zero point plus
1 m penalty 0h skip one-third m that's
the normal spacing between words plus
minus two ends and then i'll give a H
box oh no and then I'll say penalty 1000
and finally a CH skip zero point plus 1
M that all of that is one spaces all
right now in tech there's a feature now
called spec skip you could define spec
skip 12 to be zero point plus 1 m and
spec skip to to be point 33 m plus
negative 2 m's and and then you could
say just here skip one and skip to save
to save memory inside of tech and to
save some writing I mean it is so
because you would have a lot of these
spaces proliferating in the memory and
so it saves this makes it much easier
protect to refer to to something that
where you have certain kind of glue that
you're using over and over again anyway
that's just a slight optimization this
is what really goes in there for every
space in the paragraph now what is
actually happening in well I claim that
it that tech will never break at the
first one because it's always better to
break it the second one having a little
bit more stretch ability therefore I'll
consider two cases it either breaks at
this penalty or it doesn't notice it
will never break at this glue because
glue has to be following a box to be
broken and it will never break a disk
glue because that's following a penalty
and another break of this penalty
because of penalty of a thousand
is that which is the cutoff point so the
only chances are that it'll break a line
between words or won't break a line
between words so you have to consider
the two cases first what if it doesn't
break a line between two words then
there then everything gets added
together what happens the plus is
canceled 20 so there's no stretch
ability and you have a skip of three of
the normal space between words so the
words appear with their normal spacing
and there's absolutely no stretching or
shrinking the other alternative is to
break here at that point if you break
out a penalty remember it throws away
following glue until it gets to a box
and I put this box here to stop that
process as an empty box that nothing in
it but I but it'll wipe away these two
things at the end of one line at the end
of the line it'll say H skip 0 plus 1 M
the beginning of the next line it'll
have this empty box and a skip 0 plus 1
M so what's happening is I'm starting
out every line with a CH skip 0 plus 1 m
the first time we started with that the
last line is ending with that I'm also
ending every line with that and in
between where I'm not taking breaks
there's no stretching or shrinking so
the total amount of stretching in every
line and every possible SI system of
breaks is exactly 2 m's and tech we'll
look we'll compute the badness by means
of a this formula so there's really
penalties are zero and so really what
we're doing is looking at badness is the
cube of the of the amount of stretch of
bit of the amount of actual stretching
that has to be done there's no shrinking
so the lines will never get bigger than
the margin so what's happening is that
if we're minimizing the over the whole
paragraph of all possible line breaks
like this according to text formula it
turns out we're really minimizing the
sixth powers of the distances from the
margin to the to the text on each line
so so so it was sort of saying you start
at the left hand edge and calculate how
far you went in there
and then take the sixth power that some
purport some constant proportionality
and find the set of line breaks over
always to do it that minimizes the sum
of six powers or minimizing the sum of
six powers is is is it almost exactly
the same as minimizing the maximum of
the numbers so it really is saying
finding the way to break so that the
maximum distance from any left margin to
the text is as small as possible and
that will produce the shortest number of
lines and that for which it's reasonable
and also you know make the center in
effect the reason it's senator course is
that we are the 1m stretch at the left
one and stretch at the right that's the
that's the way a tech blue box of school
and penalties can be can be harnessed to
this strange job of ragged centering
similar things but easier or will give
you will give you ragged right ragged
left and the effects of that we needed
for for Pascale or a combination of of
these two things now hmm I have to say
what about getting the spaces here now
it's a little you know you could say
well let the perc let the person type
all the spaces in if you want a center
but well that's a little bit of a
nuisance so we so there's two hmm least
two ways to do this and and one of them
is to define is to is to change the code
of this of the space character to be
high 13 so change code that's octal 40
is a space character equal 13 this means
then whenever a space occurs it gets
changed into the into a control sequence
with the space this means that two
spaces in a row would be would be would
be recognized as a single spaced so on
Arthur what does that mean that's
personally have to do the same thing the
character
now if you want a carriage return then
you would leave a space and then you
would probably put a % after after a
space at the end of each line or you
could do the same thing with the
carriage return but carriage returns are
tricky the carriage returns are a little
different from from from arbitrary
symbols so so the the timing of getting
the carriage returns started and stopped
and and the fact that a line does end
with a carriage return and sometimes
well character turns out a bit or a bit
bit of a nuisance so this is one way
that we convert all the spaces that let
me see is there another way another way
is to use it is to use a process very
much like the line down your solution to
the line down problem here or the lineup
problem which would be to take the whole
paragraph and let tech just treat all
spaces the way it usually does and then
then the parameter for the argument to
the line down macro would be a bunch of
texts with spaces in it and then the
this by the same way that the line down
takes that and and put scared returns in
front of it the this this centering
macro would replace all the spaces
bye-bye bye-bye this long ritual and
until it got to the end of the parameter
list so that's ass that's a safer way to
do it without without a change without a
change core instruction change code can
sometimes lead to two problems in
inconsistencies between for men
okay now I've got two minutes left do I
have a question or should I launch into
something slightly new okay the first
thing we'll be talking about tomorrow is
the tools that Tech has for arithmetic
the at first the at first I resisted the
idea of putting a programming language
in into tech because everyone wanted to
to define this in computer science terms
but I wanted to have it more of a
descriptive thing so that the things you
type in the tech look something like the
document and rather like a then like a
program saying here's how you types at
the document giving could specific
commands however by having macros it's
turned out that that you can actually
program tech to do things by by using
macros to to execute things for example
a control sequence is like a variable
you can define it that's like setting a
value of a variable you can not only
that but tech has arithmetic it's easy
to you know is easy to add two variables
together by putting them in counters you
can set if you have a if you have a
variable if you know a control sequence
can be defined to equal minus 30 and
then another control sequence could be
defined to equal 45 and you could write
a macro that would produce a control
sequence for the sum of those two
control sequences and the difference is
also easy as you can change the sign
multiplication of integers well
multiplication by 10 is pretty easy
because you just add a 0 because we're
working in text you see you can also
reduce multiplication 22 repeated
addition so you can and then there's as
we'll see macros allow you to have
recursion so it's pretty easy to write a
multiplication
teen division isn't that hard either
because you can even multiply the
divisor by appropriate power of 10 and
subtracted as many times as you want you
can figure out the quotient and
remainder of two integers what about
floating point numbers intact well you
can also do arithmetic on knows you can
add together two dimensions because you
can you can say save 0h box and then you
can say H skip by the first dimension
and H skip the second dimension okay and
then look at the width of this box it's
the sum of the two dimensions you can
multiply dimensions because you can ask
for 33.8 times the width of this box 3.5
times over to this box would be would be
the product of some pure constant times
a dimension all right you can divide
dimensions because if I repeated
subtraction we have an if dimension
command where you can test if if one
dimension is less than another dimension
and by recursion you can you can divide
one dimension by another and get the
integer part in the remainder so
actually there are ways in in these
macros to program or something like
working a Turing machine to to bootstrap
up and do and do well operations that
could have also been put in directly at
the source level but have snuck in the
back door there a question yeah one
question but with that way of adding for
example by putting two boxes one after
another than boxing the whole thing and
taking the sides the result you get out
has got a dimension on it for instance
if you wanted that dimensional DS it's
some real number it's some some
dimension that's are some some floating
point of quantity but it's but it's got
a dimension its physical it's a physical
length and so so you so I don't mala I
don't get square inches off but this is
this is a physical length it's a
dimension whatever I mean it to it's in
units of
little things if you if you put in
millimeter and add bad five millimeters
to one inch you get some physical length
which is there so if you wanted to
divide that by some other number you
could divide one dimension by another
and find the the pure number which is
the commenting times the one goes into
the other by subtracting by adding a box
of negative width or the other one and
waiting and waiting until it drops down
or I could look i can subtract 10 times
the i could subtract 100 times the width
of one box from another one until until
until they weren't less and then i could
subtract 10 times and and and one time i
could get the quotient that way okay so
it's possible to do these operations by
you by recursive use of macros so it
snuck in the i guess the last thing that
I could say today is then one little
trick about what if you had wanted to
save a hundred different dimensions and
you wanted to get at the case one we had
an array of dimensions you wanted to
actually access the case dimension okay
well this is terrible but I thought I'd
end with with with this so suppose I
said save 0h box and then I give a skip
first dimension you know number one and
then up to H skip number 100 so and I
have 108 skips in this ennis in this box
okay then to figure out what the cave
one is you do something like this you
you unbox 0 and then you follow it by
unskilled the 100 minus K top